uh stamp his authority on this match
with a win with the white pieces so i'm
not sure exactly what opening he'll go
for he goes for the english opening
we're happy here on the panel and uh
okay both sides big experts on this
opening and did we see this one in the
world championship match we did
i think in just one game but that's
varied very quickly uh this is a brand
new position between these two at least
in recent history and uh okay right now
will magnus bring out the white knight
from the king side will he just push a
pawn this position is still relatively
well known and simon you're a big
english opening expert
yes the first opening i ever played was
the english and um um i guess it kind of
suits us doesn't it been from england um
and it's um i think i think it's a
really good opening nowadays at top
level because
uh e4 at the king's pawn opening it runs
into berlin which is incredibly well
analyzed and is is pretty equal if you
push the queen's pawn on move one again
it's so well analyzed but when you play
the english you're going for
maybe not a big advantage but you're
keeping the pieces on the board and
nothing has really is hasn't been as
analyzed as much as the other openings
so you keep better winning chances alive
i feel and what we're actually seeing
occur on the board now is a reverse
sicilian so this often occurs in this
line in english where white actually is
playing the sicilian defense which is an
opening you play with the black pieces
but you have an extra tempo and that
cuts out a lot of the dangerous lines
which you uh may well face with the
black pieces um so um already i guess
black should be equal but we've got a
position uh with a lot of play which is
good yeah and magnus especially in the
last couple of years tends to like these
types of openings just because they are
so flexible um pawn structure tends to
be very mobile white can i assume
capture this knight back with a pawn and
then push forward in the center
meanwhile black will be aiming for quick
peace development black next move is
pretty much guaranteed now he's going to
move the dark square bishop by the way
and get the black king to safety he's
going to castle okay he does take with a
queen right here the second choice in my
database it's much more common to
capture with the with the b pawn yeah
and uh the reason i'm surprised is
because magnus has won many great
victories with that pawn structure
including against anishigiri um by
taking with the pawn towards the center
instead the white queen on a decent
square but might get hit and attacked
later on so that did indeed bring the
british white gaining some space pushing
some pawns forward on the queen side i'm
expecting black to castle and the reason
i'm slightly scared to play these
positions is white and also to play the
sicilian defense as you mentioned simon
from the black side is because look at
those pieces still asleep uh next to
white's king yeah i mean they're going
to take a while to get organized that's
right i mean what what they generally
say about the sicilian which is what
magnus is really playing here is that
white has the better pawn structure
because white has more pawns in the
center of the board the center being the
most important part of the board
but white's pieces can be very very bad
black has a space advantage and black
has the better development so there's
kind of some short-term dangers to
white's position but if you get into an
ending then white generally will always
be better because he has that better
structure so um that's really what
magnus will be trying to do here get get
some pieces off i guess get into an
ending but actually he's breathing in
life maybe into a line that isn't
actually traditionally considered to be
the best one for white because here in
my database there's maybe 10 games and
they're already full victories for the
black side
so
i don't know i'm i'm kind of curious to
see what uh magnus carlsen has up his
sleeve
yeah there's a very risky strategy what
white's doing just delaying peace
development pushing pawns instead yan's
last move as black bringing the bishop
out
i mean that's surprising to me i would
have just castled the black king away
without really thinking but then again i
guess possibly one of the ideas as black
is to actually play on the side that
white has been advancing maybe black at
some point will start pushing pawns the
black a pawn can come down the board
undermining the white pawns that have
just pushed forward so flexible play by
both sides it feels like they're both
going to be freestyling over the next
few moves and it will come down to who
can just place their piece pieces on the
best squares so
i'm expecting magnus as a matter of
urgency to start developing some of
those white pieces we see um in the
corner there because if he doesn't it
might be too late as ivanka mentioned
black has a great score from this type
of position and that's just because
black's plans are much easier than
whites maybe yeah and i can tell you
that um just checking the database
no one has ever played the move that
napoleon has played so that's it you
know you kind of hit it spot on when you
said they're freestyling and now they
most certainly will be
and uh wow interesting position here
and
if you guys at home want to be involved
in the conversation in all the action
then don't hesitate to tweet us your
chess questions using the hashtag chess
champs we also really like to see your
selfies show us where you're watching
the show from how you're watching it and
we will feature them
definitely
okay meanwhile magnus just bringing his
knight out very sensible move finally
starting to focus on his peace
development
and uh simon whose position would you
prefer here it's already imbalanced it's
likely we're going to get a big big
fight in this one with both sides trying
to attack yeah generally i i i
always like playing the side which has
the more space i find it easier to to
find the right plan when i've got more
space to maneuver and
in this position actually black has more
space because white's kind of really
huddled on the first three rows
and black has that fourth row black can
very easily castle here has a little bit
better development so i i would i would
actually take black um in in this
position because it's easier to play uh
i'm wondering i don't think he's going
to do it i really hope he does
i really hope jan is going to go
queenside which looks kind of suicidal
when white's already advanced his pawns
at the board but when you have castling
on opposite sides of the board it makes
the position extremely interesting i
don't think he's going to do it but i
would love it if he did because it would
be you know really really dynamic and
interesting move i mean the other thing
you can do is black is try to connect
your pawn in the center with another
pawn and so you can move freddie up the
board maybe even two squares at some
stage castle king's side and try to
start an attack with those two pawns and
also this idea black has moving the
knight into the center in some positions
is is what white needs to watch out for
in in this kind of sicilian structure
yeah i was actually going to show this
because on the last move magnus decided
to focus on bringing his pieces out
which is very wise
some players at home might have been
thinking okay i can push this pawn even
further forward gain even more space
kicking away the black knight but this
would have run into a really thematic
typical type of sacrifice here that
could bring his knight into the middle
as simon mentioned and due to tension
along this line white cannot actually
capture this knight if you take with the
pawn then suddenly whoops that's a
discover check and the white queen next
move will fall and uh likewise if the
white knight had captured then after
this trade still a pin on this line and
after white's queen takes this pawn that
would have been a nasty pin and a bit of
a skewer along this line the white queen
moving out the way would drop the white
rook so magnus bringing out his bishop
on the last turn instead very sensible
develop your pieces first and then push
pawns later and jan just pushes this
pawn to solidify his stronghold in the
center ashley simon i think you're right
i think he's gearing up at some point if
he can to castle this way and then maybe
launch these pawns down the board
i'm hoping that i'm hoping yeah because
i love it when you have opposite side
castling because um i i love attacking
chess and opposite side castling always
leads to well material becomes less
relevant you just have to throw throw
all your pawns and pieces at your
opponent's king and you you get this
really exciting game so fingers crossed
yan is going to go queenside here uh in
the position i it does seem so risky
with white having an open file towards
the black king and also that pawn sort
of on already ready to pounce over there
but uh you know i could be very very
nervous to do that um precisely because
of the reasons that you mentioned and
also because i would be afraid
if i were to focus on the right side i
would be afraid that black's attack is a
little bit too slow because yes you can
push the pawns forward but how long will
it take before i even even get into
contact with the whiteboard it does seem
slow and tempo's so important in these
positions because
if you're slower than your opponent
you're going to lose generally um it's
the kind of thing yan should be going
for as we discussed earlier on that yan
wants to get a dynamic position this
move that magnus played has probably
brought oh hello he's come in wow okay
what a move by janna ponechi jumping in
i don't think it's a porn sacrifice
because now again if pawn takes knight
this is check a discovered check and the
white queen will drop on the next move
and uh as you mentioned ivanka white can
take this night with his own knight but
this pawn is now poisoned if white gets
tempted to take it with this queen then
again this idea of the skewer along this
diagonal the queen will move out of the
way but the white bishop will drop
behind it so really sneaky from yana
pognishi and maybe he's just set a trap
for magnus and magnus has walked right
into it because now it's a bit
uncomfortable for white maybe white just
ignores it or maybe white trades a set
of knights and then just moves the queen
out of the way okay i think this is
going to happen he's not going to take
this pawn he's just going to move his
queen the problem is where do you move
it to you could drop it back and argue
that okay it was just a fair trade but
somehow it feels like maybe the momentum
is in black's favor despite what the
evaluation bar says
let's go back to the players it's
heating up with this flurry of tactics
already starting early in the game
are we seeing what you sort of asked
from jan in this game his style is he
bringing his style to this game feels
like he's definitely trying yeah magnus
so far just trying to neutralize him
after this kind of flashy night move
into the center magnus just saying okay
i'm just going to trade off pieces i'm
going to retreat i'm going to just be
super solid and trying to lock things
down but yan as black you can't really
ask for a more dynamic position from the
opening right
yeah yeah it looks good i mean it is
kind of strange that all the knights
have been exchanged off already and so
in some ways that's also going towards
what magnus probably wants for his
structure like those extra pawns in the
middle he wants to exchange pieces off
but
bishops only bishops on the boards is
really uh quite interesting and i think
it's going to come down to if white can
get castled i expect white's going to be
better here white wants to castle
kingside because he's got a nice
structure he's got some nice advanced
pawns slightly better bishops is there
any way that yan he's got two moves to
do that white just wants to move his
bishop that hasn't been developed move
his king can yan stop
magnus from castling because if you can
then you keep this kind of initiative
going is there any way you can do that
do you think david here yeah i mean
that's that's the key question right and
i'm struggling to find a way immediately
unless you start pushing pawns as black
but that involves some risk as well um
any pawns that black pushes forward will
leave weak squares behind
um so that's the decision jan has to
make that's why he kind of looked off to
the side and frowned a bit he knows if
he doesn't seize the moment now then
white will be very very comfortable at
the minimum yeah
the only way in response to your
question that i see is like picking up
the c pawn and moving it one square
just uh activate the light squared
bishop if possible if you can yeah that
that would be very nice to try and just
improve your pieces as black here
after this move it makes a lot of sense
because also the queen
um could be the white queen could be a
target to uh blackrook uh coming in oh
here we go that's more like this simon
is happy
there this is too razor sharp this
position now uh now it's going to be get
nervous moment i love positions like
this and uh you got to i mean he's doing
the right thing isn't he because we we
said he's got to go for it he's got to
try to attack um but castling into that
open line it's incredibly risky inside
castle that's usually very entertaining
right always very entertaining
especially if the kings both end up on
opposite sides and um just before white
gets a chance to castle on this flank
yan's played a very surprising move i
must admit retreating his queen i
thought maybe the king would tuck away
to safety he stepped back with his queen
hitting this pawn with help from the
black bishop now is there the first
thing the strings springs to mind here
okay he's gone for the queen exchange
boom
[Music]
i know that's why i thought because if
the bishop blocks you you have this
maybe queen coming in the middle as well
and uh i don't know if that works but
coming to the center and now it's a
double pin you're pinning this way
pinning this way it's really complicated
i guess white could have just defended
his bishop here um the other move uh
very tempting in this position would be
now to offer the queen trade as jan has
done and now there's a big trick in the
position if white trades queens you
don't actually catch your back yet you
flick in what we call as vishenzug an in
between move you play bishop takes
bishop check first and when the king
moves only then you take back the queen
and black would have won a bishop in the
meantime so jan may be missing a small
opportunity to disturb magnus it's just
surprising he rushed that last move
instead of giving a really annoying
check to white's king he offers the
queen trade and remember we saw the aim
chess stats magnus is ahead in the end
games and we're headed towards that end
game now uh the queen trade and harry
marching up the board didn't you say he
shouldn't take the queen back right away
um in this position it was fine but
that's why we thought maybe jan should
have flicked in a check first and then
magnus couldn't have taken the queens
off
so
yeah very surprising that jan rushed to
get the queens off because that seems to
favor magnus's style and so notice how
quickly magnus has played these last
couple of moves he's happier now it's
still maybe a little bit tricky for
white to decide where his king goes here
even though the queens are off and we're
getting to a safer position where does
white put his king here because
um
does he go queen side or or king side
leave it in the middle i wouldn't be
sure what to do here with the white king
leave it in the middle leave it in the
middle yeah
then you'll work is that an advantage
because then he's magnus has uh used to
move to to castle with sort of the
unsaved move if he decides not to castle
uh yeah if uh magnus decides not to
castle he could well save a movement i
mean sorry magnus yeah
i mean if white's king just for example
if the white light squared bishop moves
out of the way in front of white's king
then the king could just step up one
square it's well protected by pawns
you have to be a bit careful about the
diagonals but
if all the rooks disappear white's king
might well be better placed than the
black king later and this is the reason
why i said put it in the middle because
i felt that there would be a check it
has to put it in the middle because he's
got no choice yeah
very safe despite the fact
there are still heavy pieces like rooks
on the board
i expect the white bishops to try and
cover any entry squares that the black
rooks want to use to get into white's
position
well what a first game in the final
super entrance intense and interesting
exactly and a brand new position already
on move eight as your vanco mentioned um
that shows the players they're not
scared of just going down these new
avenues and uh trying to surprise each
other each other yeah
yeah i mean there's a lot of play in
this position as well i mean i
do you find it easier playing with
knights or bishops or does it does it
kind of make any difference to you um i
mean i i think i
have certain positions i play better and
i like it when there's it's actually
more closed and i i think i prefer
playing with knights i don't know what
it is but um is there any preference
like or not really i prefer playing
closed positions
but ironically between the knight and
the bishop i would choose the bishop
right just because they're easier to
kind of get a grip on you know one color
complex they just move diagonally
backwards forwards to this
and the knights are tricky you know they
jump all over the place yeah yeah i mean
it's strange i mean this level the the
way the top players use the bishops
is quite incredible when you when you
you know they really do value the bishop
pair uh so much i think lower down the
bishop pair is a little bit overrated
i got crucified for saying that once
before
i said the bishop pair is overrated and
i think i got like you know
so many messages saying
no
you're wrong but i i i kind of do but a
top-level bishop perez is is just so so
important um but i mean it looks fairly
even at the moment this to me the
position looks very even and it will be
fascinating to see who maneuvers their
bishop pair later um in better um in
more kind of effective ways so
um yeah i'm inclined to agree with both
of you in a way i like playing against
knights actually they're easier to
dominate bishops are so tricky um to
kind of either they're just great
attacking pieces or they're great
defenders and okay yan meanwhile pushing
pawns on the side he's stronger it's not
just the fact that there's a bit of an
imbalance between the kings but also
black has a three versus two advantage
on this side white has a four versus
three pawn advantage on the other flank
and maybe it's easier for black to push
his pawns right now if white pushes any
pawns near the white king
that will leave some weaknesses so okay
interesting move by jan and on passant
is possible here white can actually
capture that pawn as if it just moved
one square but that would just be a
trade uh maybe we can just show this on
the board what happens
so the black pawn pushing forward and on
means in passing and white has captured
this point in passing as if it just
moved one square i heard a funny story
about the on pass on broad it was uh one
of the only i think mickey adams like
england's uh top player really of this
uh last 10 20 years um he he lost the
game to to neil macdonald who's another
grand master but much lower rated
because he forgot about the on pass on
brawl um i'm amazed by that last move
but mickey adams one of the best players
he forgot about on pass on and the
ending uh which which is quite
surprising yeah and you said you're
surprised by this last move i'm i'm
speechless almost this last move yeah it
looks logical to take with the bishop
you keep these two pawns connected you
open up your bishop on a nice diagonal
you open up your rook on a nice line
instead yan capturing back with a pawn
he's isolated his own pawns and
if knights were on the board this would
be a fatal mistake maybe without knights
on the board it's not so bad having
isolated pawns because they can't be
blockaded they can't be targeted so
easily but still it looks very
surprising very counter-intuitive
to me what do you think about that
decision i hate it so much um primarily
because you know take a look at black's
king it's not safe anymore
i mean you know you can just see a
scenario where if black tries to
like like david is highlighting check is
certainly all going to be an idea that
magnus is going to be thinking about i'm
also going to be thinking about uh
targeting that isolated c pawn and just
moving the rook to open line and if it
steps forward well then black will try
to initiate a trade of dark squared
bishops um it's a bold bold move white
would go for the trade track yeah white
will go for the trade yeah and it's got
a past porn though yeah i mean that's
wonderful that is the one thing that's
why i think it's brave yeah brave brave
decision well we know he's a brave chap
already i don't like it though
i would never play that move um
i i ever i mean but maybe that's why
he's sitting there and i'm sitting here
right i mean it's a it's quite an
incredible idea because the other move
it looks so natural doesn't it just uh
played a bishop to a better square i
mean would you what about you david i
mean would you i think i would have
captured this way automatically to be
honest the one downside behind this one
we've talked about the downsides to the
other move but the one downside to
taking with the bishop is i guess white
is able to install a bishop on an
outpost and it's hard to challenge this
piece now um this piece stares off at
black's pawns but also completely blocks
the open file so okay pros and cons but
that's why as you mentioned simon these
players are sitting there they're the
best in the world because they know when
to follow kind of conventional wisdom
but also when to break the rules when to
do something a bit different a bit
surprising and yan's capture with the
pawn
maybe you never know maybe this pawn
will just run through and promote and
we'll say okay this was strategic genius
but uh yeah that's yet to be seen so far
really tense this end game position
still bar saying 0.0 uh what do you say
is it very george or is uh anything
possible i would say both sides have
chances but neither side has the
advantage so it's still far far away
from a draw but uh yeah i think 0.0 is
fair here as long as we're not thinking
it's a draw as long as we're thinking
okay chances for both sides and will the
kings sort of join the attack quite soon
or or do we need more pieces off the
board before that happens i think blacks
might well step up the board kind of
support its pawns you've got to be
careful of checks if the rooks come off
the kings would definitely play a major
role
in the game but
i would be uncomfortable with magnus
having the king in the way of connecting
the two white rooks yeah but i actually
think you're right kaya the kings will
probably play a very crucial role in
this stage of the game um the white king
will play the role because if you take a
look at the rook on the right side it's
kind of trapped in by its king so that
white king has to find a safe house
might not be easy because the vision
position is super open black's king is
looking a little bit shaky as well and
remember double bishop double bishop
bishop pear is what i wanted to say i
mean they are going to start putting
pressure and you combine that with a
pair with a pair of rooks then okay who
knows what could be happening you might
even see me wow and on the bottom of the
screen right now you can actually see
what the players are fighting for in
addition to
25 000
the winner will take home that nft
trophy and actually exists in two uh
versions also one uh that will be
available for or that is available for
auction to the highest bidder on chess
champs.i and there comes a bunch of
perks with that nft trophy that you can
buy
among others i know there's a lifetime
of chess 24 premium lifetime of
chessable pro and last time i checked
the highest bid was only around 70
dollars
yeah wow you can get a lot of stuff if
you uh
run into chess jumps dot io and bid for
that special nft trophy does it come as
a hologram
i don't
i mean could we put it on our table like
star wars kind of like you know because
then i'm interested so i quite like that
i could put it on my desk and it'd be
like i'll just stare at it oh yeah
just for those perks alone it's one of
the bargains i know it's a bargain of a
lifetime i was reading through the list
of things that you get along with the
trophy and it's nice
i mean the chess 24 the the chess ball
pro all these things are really useful
if you want to improve your chest so
certainly exactly and also i mean in
what do i know five years 10 years that
nft trophy which will also
it will exist in
the version that you own
one for air things the sponsor and one
for the winner of the tournament so you
can sort of share
very unique stuff and maybe it will be
worth
so much money in five years or ten years
one thing i've been reading about nfts
because they've kind of exploded all
over the internet and everyone is
talking about them is that they have
this concept of easter eggs ah so you
know you think it's just a normal
picture or something but hidden within
it there's something something special
something very special and that this
will later become known and you can kind
of collect those special things exactly
so yeah exciting exciting all right
moves yeah meanwhile moves and really
exciting now on the board white has just
given up a piece for a pawn but he's
going to get the piece back look at this
white is a piece down but he's brought
his rook across and that's a pin that
black dark square bishop is about to
drop off the board really surprising
yandere formula she went for this i
guess his idea at some point over the
next couple of turns is to take white
pawn on the side of the board with the
black light squared bishop and it will
be level pawns but look how open the
black king is if white's rook in the
corner was somehow able to jump into the
action as well black's king would be in
mortal danger but okay really risky
strategy from the pontiac is he going to
take this pawn or is he going to try and
trade a set of rooks
either way black is a pawn down right
now having fallen victim to that pin and
he needs to justify it
trade works
trade works because i'm a scaredy cat i
thought you'd love grabbing pawns what's
happening okay he's gone for the trader
rooks i would have
would you have i would have thought
about grabbing the pawn because if i get
away of it then i i would like to play
it but okay he's he's gone for the this
way to activate and he's you know he'll
take those pieces maybe that pawn is
just going to drop anyway yeah in the
position right right
now yeah uh i think you should take it
before uh it gets defended this looks
all right for black i mean because all
of a sudden
he's got very nice past porn um talked
about the kings as well black's king is
going to be a great supporter of the
black pawn once it starts rolling down
the board
it looks good i mean yeah i mean
past pawn in the ending is very useful
yeah with that king you mentioned david
and uh your rook's all right i mean i
i'd probably take black here i wouldn't
if anything black every time i'm
surprised the computer still says 0.0
slightly on black side now because it
just looks easier for black to play and
black has no risk at all once you
capture that white pawn
that black pawn as we mentioned it's
going to run down the board the black a
pawn it will act as a distraction and
maybe if white's pieces get too carried
away there we go white's pawn dropping
off uh if white's pieces get too carried
away trying to stop that remaining black
pawn on the left side then maybe black
will switch his attention with his rook
towards the white pawns on the other
flank so okay level pawns now we saw a
check there a block by black's bishop
that's quite rare and chess meeting a
check with a check uh so white gave a
check then black blocked with his bishop
giving a check but now where is the
white king going to go
okay both kings activating kaya it's as
if you got your magic ball and spotted
the future because the kings are
marching up the board now i would love
to see black's king advance even further
right now as well
to maybe step in front or uh next to the
black bishop so there's a bit of
opposition between the two kings
maybe black could give another check
with his rook black could push upon lots
of choices it's quite a funny line isn't
it if you check with the rook and the
white king steps up again i mean i was
thinking on the third rank there that it
would actually be checkmate with uh with
a pawn which is uh just uh
there's been some cases where someone's
trying to use their king too much in the
ending and uh this is one case where you
don't bring your king forwards because
uh yeah you always even in the ending
have to be careful of king's safety and
that'd be quite embarrassing and this
checkmate has a name
we know it now david and goliath
checkmate yeah really
oh
it's for simon david sorry oh let me
just have a thing called it's called
yeah
is it david and goliath checkmates
yes thank you well done simon
why is it called david and goliath
because uh david did you make that up
for her no no no right was the truth
david clayton david is always the
underdog it's a pawn against a giant
like a king ah okay yes that sounds like
it's not a real thing to me i reckon you
made that up
i don't believe it meanwhile let's catch
up with the play there have been a few
moves so black bringing black checking
the white king back away from an active
post this white king not as well placed
now and blacks rook came down attacking
this white pawn and magnus has chosen to
defend it with the white rook slightly
surprising but then again i think
magnus's idea is to get active with this
rook somehow and to do that he might
push this pawn forward for example if
black starts pushing on the side he's
stronger okay he brings his bishop to
the side then white would push forward
and if we see a trade then this white
rook at least activates it can maybe
threaten some stuff along the fifth rank
you can go towards black's pawns as well
so uh in this position instead yan
brought his bishop to the side he's
threatening a really annoying check he's
trying to break through onto the second
rank not just checking the king but also
trying to snack on the white pawns
there's lots of targets on the second
row what is now the goal for both black
and white as a to promote pawns
most likely long term while the rooks
remain there's targets for the rooks to
try and pick up pawns
like this black rook coming to the
second rank but if the rooks disappear
especially then black has this pawn
which will run down the board and maybe
promote or at least act as a distraction
and meanwhile white it's harder for
white because these four how do you
create a pass pawn against black's three
over here it's very very difficult
anytime you push a pawn as white it will
just get traded off so if anything black
is a bit faster with his pawn it's
actually the double pawns for black kind
of good right now yeah and it's all
about knights we talked about knights
having left the board very early in this
game doubled pawns can be easily
targeted by knights but against bishops
much much more difficult to target them
and look at this magnus just going for
it trying to open up his rook we see a
trade and white's rook has activated
black may well try and win a pawn though
this is a check the white king does not
want to get cut off on its bottom row
because now this king is in just a
terrible position completely
stranded along this line so it steps
forward gaining time against the black
bishop
black's bishop once it retreats
not sure where it gets where it's going
to but
say it takes a step back then black has
targets also some
kind of outline of a mating attack for
example if white gets greedy and goes
for the black pawn we could see a
situation where black maybe brings the
bishop to the side this capture and then
oh it looks like checkmate may be coming
against the white king you've got to be
a bit careful here with white what's
that one called then uh ivanka yeah
checkmate expert yeah yeah they have to
keep asking you know no this one doesn't
have a name make one up there you can
trick me
check me the yo v checkmate checkmate
yeah i like that one actually yeah the
baby check mate there you go okay good
yeah
good
and uh well the skeleton of that
checkmate is on the board
black just needs two moves just maybe
push the pawn forward to cover the dark
squares uh and then you bring the bishop
forward to close the cage around the
white king so magnus has to be super
careful we've seen him get checkmated
before
on last season's champions chess tour
several times
in an end game though he tends to be
quite
alert so okay this is really scary
magnus ignoring black's plans and just
going for the pawns instead
so
yeah it's a bit scary isn't it so
so if you go for the checkmate you
mentioned i guess you can you can get by
and get a check in can he yeah i'm just
looking at which is the most correct
move order and i think david's got the
right one up there
not clear
if you move the bishop then after rook
takes pawn it looks like you're closing
the door and about to make white but as
simon said you can flick in a check with
white and wherever the king goes the
white rook oh it can't stand back yeah
it can't step back because this this way
you get checkmated too
what absolutely magnus playing with fire
well you win the rook don't you that way
yeah so yeah yeah actually that's that's
not so clear is it actually yeah
it's complicated
i thought the uh i thought the white
rook would drop here but suddenly
there's a pin at the very end and
still very very complicated position
this end game has magnus calculated this
all has jan calculated this or this is
the question in the current position
magnus has to decide can he take this
pawn or is he going to get checkmated if
that happens
i would hate to be white right now i
checked the computer options and uh
guess what there's only one move to
survive in the game and it's actually
not capturing the pawn
the best move is actually to attack the
rook with the bishop wow this is not
easy moving this bishop off a very safe
square and moving it to the center to
destabilize the black rook it looks like
you simply lose time but i guess the
idea is after the black rook moves
captures the pawn for example white's
king is free to run out of the corner
oh magnus gotta find this
he's gotta find this move yeah that we
see stock fish the computer confirms
only one move and it's this one
everything else gives black a big big
advantage wow what is magnus then doing
now and he finds it it's impressive
yours finds it doesn't it yeah
nice just when you think you've got your
hopes up and you're about to check make
the world champion he goes it's just
fine
not going to happen today
that's the thing maybe he was just
forced to find good moves i think we've
mentioned this theme before um sometimes
no matter what the strength if you force
your opponent to find the only moves
they most likely will just by process of
elimination
cave though still
to me it looks hard to defend with white
it feels like black will be the favorite
once that pawn that black pawn starts
pushing but then again the pony actually
shaking his head maybe just frustrated
that he
uh
underestimated this defense or that he
mis was maybe banking on magnus missing
it you don't really need a computer when
you've got yandy you mean you can just
look at his face
he will tell you the assessment of the
position right so it's the it's the yam
bar so i like it you know
you can see he mis i don't know if he
missed that move but the position is not
as strong as he he thought it i thought
it was i think yeah
okay but yeah fair play to magnus
finding that one yeah there we go the
white king before it's too late before
it gets completely trapped has run away
and gains time against the black bishop
that's the justification behind white's
previous move i've noticed that jan very
rarely i don't know if i've ever heard
him speak you know nice about his own
chess playing he's always very negative
about his own games
is he a perfectionist basically he's
definitely a perfectionist he holds
himself to high standards he's his own
fiercest critic and actually i think
that's the same for lots of sportsmen
you very rarely hear magnus as well
praise his own play despite the fact
magnus often plays great
games where he controls it all um often
later they're saying ah i lost control
for one move or this one slip maybe it
was only the third best move not the top
yeah
i mean
i wish i was
harsh on myself maybe that's why i'm not
at that level but um yeah either way
it's just about finding that balance
between enjoying chess but also
pushing yourself to be better every time
it's kind of what we heard from young
pragnanda as well right when we talked
to him after he won against magnus
carlsen the whole world has been
praising him
but he was a little bit annoyed about
that game because there were some moves
he didn't like and he was more happy
about yeah his win against livonronian
aronian
exactly i was surprised at that because
i thought he would just be
you know absolutely overwhelmed with
happiness
but no he was just simply well you know
these are the things i did wrong now i
need to go back to the board and fix
them so i mean i was really impressed by
his kind of learning mindset that he
obtained and also just not to have these
big swings of emotion because when you
do
have those kind of emotional thoughts on
the board they do affect your play you
know you either get stressed you get
happy you let you let like happy
thoughts run away and then you think
you're winning but then you're not and
then yeah and then just effects on how
resourceful you can be yeah and i guess
emotions uh was what got in the way for
janna pogba in the world championship
match very emotional there yeah
exactly you often saw him leaving the
board maybe just because he was
struggling to control his nerves um
clearly between the games maybe at night
in the morning
he just wasn't able to get in a rhythm
be himself and fully relax and it's
difficult world championship it's like a
pressure cooker where everything is
heightened a hundred times
um so it's understandable that nerves
got in the way or that
just he seems a much more emotional
player doesn't he yan not just magnus
carlsen but a lot of their players
playing this tournament maybe he's the
most emotional him in espienko they're
both very uh show a lot of emotion when
they're playing um which can be good and
bad i guess you get quite excited your
energy levels can go up but they can
also fade very quickly nice for the fans
nice for us watching
meanwhile some checks forcing the black
king potentially to a worse square where
it will continue to get targeted the
black king now in the middle of the
board but once white's bishop steps away
from this attack
i'm expecting it to just take a step
back okay in this direction uh is fine
too now the problem is for black that
his pieces aren't coordinating to
support that black pawn on the a file
next move for example if black goes and
gets greedy and takes one of the white
pawns with his rook then white's rook is
just going to step back and gobble up
that black a pawn and this one might be
heading towards the draw in the next few
moves looks like great defense by magnus
carson yeah but but now we can sort of
see that yan's uh move which i don't
think any of us
were gonna play taking on c6 the pawn it
worked out incredibly well because if
anyone had chances after that it was
actually yan uh magnus had to find that
quite tough defensive move
uh which she did he did obviously find
and well okay black is a pawn up here
but white's so active not even a porno i
know it's not okay right yeah yeah so
it's uh we're racing towards the draw
now we're about to see it any second
we're just going to see checks the
position's about to repeat itself the
first game of the final ends in a draw
wow magnus carlsen with the white pieces
it is a draw this first game in uh the
first match in the final magnus logging
off yana pomiacci